forget about the drama of politics less
than a mile down the road from number 10
george clooney and julia roberts
reunited for a good old-fashioned
rom-com that's certainly not to be taken
too seriously or is it i thought of this
as a drama i thought this was really
trying to depict
some of the
horrible things that are going on
around the world it's so hopeless isn't
it dc
it's hopeless you cannot get a straight
answer i'm thinking about a trojan horse
sort of thing make her think we're okay
with the wedding and then once we're in
we get her to end it herself
that's literally what i just said
playing warring exes who reunite to stop
the wedding of their daughter to a
seaweed farmer in bali like in the film
i don't think there's 30 seconds that go
by that she doesn't say something
humiliating about me which it cracks me
up but in a in a nice in a very rotten
nice way sometimes subtle sometimes not
so soft not so subtle although both now
are married to other people their big
scream chemistry has seen them play
husband and wife for over 20 years now
promotions 11 and 12 through to this
latest film which was written especially
for them
it includes some impressive drunken
dance moves but was any alcohol consumed
to bring out scenes like these
not a drop
but julia does a lot of drugs so it
really doesn't matter because she you
can't drink and do those kind of
hallucinogens
a lot of mushrooms and things like that
no we didn't while the film couldn't be
further away from politics given their
enduring popularity how about some
advice for our new prime minister on how
to last a little longer than her
predecessor well is isn't it day one yep
so well we as uh as we always say you
wish the best because there's a lot of
things coming up a lot of a lot of big
issues coming out a lot of
uh financial worries for the the whole
country so we all hope that she does her
best and we hope that there's uh some
great luck in it because it's a it's a
tough time for everybody this is no
women to be terribly clever don't we
george
we do a compliment of sorts coming from
hollywood royalty katie spencer sky news